hey what's going on everybody
uh it's cameron let me know that you
guys can hear me okay and see me okay i
assume you guys can see me okay but let
me know
if you can hear me okay i've had a
little bit of tactical issues today
let me know
if you can hear me okay
looks like we got quite a few people
here today which is awesome
awesome awesome
this is all good awesome thank you
awesome awesome yep okay cool okay so
guys this is the um the first of
what i'm calling motion science live and
i'm going to
um
start doing these on tuesdays it's not
going to be every tuesday
but as many tuesdays at 1 pm eastern
time as i can as i can fit into my
schedule i'm going to show up here live
and i'm going to talk to you guys about
some good stuff
so uh hey it's great to see you kermit
moe
david cruz alexander
eva
blacksmouth alexandra hey what's going
on man
uh
griff graffen griffin
um
devex what's going on devx 550 dan lewis
all right
um
what else we got david cruz okay awesome
okay so i'm not gonna not gonna talk for
a whole long time here
someone said adrian said not the best
time to go live with adobe max i don't
care right i'm not adobe max i'm here to
teach you guys some stuff
so um what i'm gonna talk to you guys
about today just briefly i'm going to
open up for some questions afterwards
is i want to talk to you guys about
i'm not going to do any screen sharing
today i'm going to talk to you guys
about how i got started in motion design
because i get asked a lot like how do i
get started emotions on maybe you're
brand new to motion design and you've
never been in motion design
professionally maybe you're in it
working
doing motion design but you want to up
level maybe your job or what you're
doing or change your your direction in
motion design
so i got asked a lot like how did i get
from zero to hero basically is what i
would say i just came up with that but
um as in terms of hero i would say it's
a professional right and a professional
is anybody who's getting paid to do
motion design
so
um
before i jump into that i want to know
from you guys
do you guys does anyone here remember
the first
motion design piece that they ever saw
that you ever saw
um
that or even more importantly like that
you noticed
right like you saw this piece
and maybe it was on tv maybe it's on the
the web
and it just kind of blew your mind and
you're like what is that right you
didn't know what motion design was yet
but you saw this piece
and it kind of opened your eyes to like
okay this is what motion design is i
want to know how to do it
excuse me so
what is that piece for you
right for me
it was the movie seven the title
sequence to seven i hear that um a lot
as well from people who follow motion
science
that they saw the movie seven this was a
title sequence that came out in 1995
um
that blew my mind right
so let's see what you guys
uh anda
says 3d camera tutorial awesome awesome
that's a good one that's the first piece
i ever put out there
dan lewis 557 like a lot of people
amazing
um
givenchy
seven title sequence amazing
ricardo yes mtv and hv1 commercial cuts
uh yeah mtv for me was
hugely influential
made a huge impact on me
especially back in the day
um no it doesn't end that's okay it
doesn't have to be one of my pieces um i
i get i hear a lot too that 3d camera
techniques you know inspired a lot of
people
ricardo vh1 okay vh1 on mtv
seven
two advanced website back in the day
uh tv movie intros from the 80s for all
my favorite shows star wars star trek
etc carnival yeah carnival's a good one
we actually made a title sequence based
on that title sequence in one of our
many courses here at motion science
um
true detective yes amazing title
sequence i was fortunate enough to get
to work
uh with many people who worked on that
and who designed that was a good buddy
of mine
catch me if you can intro
mid-80s mtv
yes
tom and jerry i don't know okay that
works too
um so um mine like i said was the movie
seven the title sequence seven um but um
i'll get back to that in a little bit
cause i have a good story about how
seven was influential to me and how it
kind of came full circle to me
um so who am i if you don't know who i
am uh my name is cameron piron i have 20
plus years of experience in after
effects
started in after effects in 1999
okay so i've been working after effects
for a long time
i started my first motion graphics
company in 2003 with my very best friend
very small company
in 2005 two years after that i went
through some really rough patches of my
life my personal life
so i decided to quit that company even
though i was doing really well and i
went to work for a regional company
doing motion graphics
in 2006 one year later i was still
working for that company but i started
moonlighting
for a variety of companies just kind of
moonlighting freelancing on the side
kind of see what else was out there
then a year later i became a remote
freelancer 2007 became a remote
freelancer
back in that day
um
remote freelancing was
something that people were like really
questioned
uh like how can you be a remote
freelancer and work for these companies
you have to be there and and that wasn't
me i kind of bucked the system and it
worked
and my very first
remote freelance client was kyle cooper
and he is the guy who created the seven
title sequence so in 1995 i saw the
seven title sequence
i sat on it for four years just kind of
being inspired by it
and then in 1999 i saw another piece
that really inspired me and i kind of
jumped in and started learning after
effects
and then in 2007 here i am working for
kyle cooper so
pretty amazing experience for me um and
then last thing about me
i went on as a freelancer to work for
some amazing clients
i worked for 343 industries amazon
cmt cnn dell discovery disney
i'm just going through a list here
microsoft mgm mtv i did work for mtv on
many occasions the pga rca records sony
scifi
xbox wwe network the list goes on and on
um i've had the opportunity to work with
a lot of big clients so i've had a lot
of professional experience in motion
design
so i didn't go from
no experience
to a pro overnight
and
that's just really important to realize
because a lot of people
come to me and they say well i just want
to i want to be a professional right now
and you have to understand that it takes
some time
to get into that world you have to start
somewhere but the more you practice
the better you're going to be the
quicker you're going to get better at at
this
um at motion design
so you guys are fortunate enough to have
things like courses
youtube
online mentors to really push you
back when i got started
there was none of that okay
so
how i got started was i bought a book on
after effects there was one book at the
bookstore and i can't remember the name
of it
i can remember the cover of it but it
was the only book at the time about
after effects and um what would happen
is like i would go to my day job
every day i had my day job
i would work at the day job i would come
home
i had a baby boy at the time and
i would come home my wife would leave
for work
and i would take care of the baby boy
and after i did all my dad duties and he
was asleep
i would open up my after effects book
and i would start studying after effects
right i would just read through this
book
and it was more on the technical side so
when i started in motion design it was
really more on the technical side of
things i didn't understand design
never took a design course in my life or
a class anything just
no design experience but i started
learning the technical side of it
and i did this five to six nights a week
like i just i stayed up super late i
studied study study as much as i could
and just absorbed as much knowledge as i
could
now this was before the days of youtube
um so like i said this is to date myself
this was back in 1999 2000. um youtube
didn't come around until 2005.
so
i would just study everything i could in
this one book and then i would look for
blog posts online um there was a few of
them like creative cow and things like
that
that i would go to and get some
additional information from
so
keep in mind
in order for me to really
take what i was learning about after
effects and put into practice i had to
have a computer and i didn't have a
computer okay
so
i was i managed to get a credit card and
it had a two thousand dollar limit on it
and
i took out a two thousand dollar
i had this credit card and i bought this
my first apple computer
now two thousand dollars at that time
was in a significant amount of money to
me
it was two months of salary for me and
at that time i was supporting my baby
boy and my wife
and
it in reality it took me over a year i
knew it would take me over a year to pay
off that apple computer but i knew i had
to take a risk i had to have some type
of i had to put some skin in the game i
had to take a risk
and
i couldn't really practice after effects
without a computer so i bought that
computer
and again
five to six nights a week i would come
home and now i would start practicing on
the computer
what i learned in this book
i also started creating spec work okay
and for any of those who have listened
to any any talks i've ever given about
spec work
i'm a huge believer in it right if you
don't have if you don't create spec work
i don't believe
i believe that it takes you a lot longer
to get
better at this craft right to get paid
for what you do
so
i started creating spec work
and it was as many things different
things i could think of to create and
i'm talking about like logo animations
for made up companies i would do title
work for made up companies
simple just random animations with
shapes and things like that
and i built my very first demo reel
and it was all spec work right it was
100 spec work no clients were paying me
to do this no clients hiring me to do
this i just built a basic
minute and a half demo reel of spec work
and what i did with that that first demo
reel is i sent it off to multiple
companies
and guess what i got rejected
every time time after time one company
actually tried to hire me they brought
me in i drove like hours away to this
interview
and i found out that they actually want
to hire me as an editor based upon my
demo reel because like the timing was
really great to music and i was kind of
taken back by that nothing against video
editing it just wasn't what i wanted to
do right i wanted to be a full-time
motion designer
so
the next best thing is i decided to
start my own company as i mentioned
earlier with my best friend so we
started a little post-production company
he did the video shooting and editing
and i did the motion graphics
so we were mixing motion graphics with
with video we were working for different
corporate clients um we did that for two
years
and you know there were some okay jobs
and there a lot of the jobs were were
real
boring i guess i would say they paid the
bills
there was a few pieces throughout the
two years that i was like okay this
could be a demo real worthy uh track or
piece in my in my demo reel
excuse me
so
for two years i did client work with my
little company and i created more spec
work i knew that if i wanted to go to
that next level i had to create more
spec work and keep pushing myself that's
why spec work's so important you keep
pushing yourself you keep doing what you
love to create you keep making that but
you push yourself you learn more and you
get better right
so two years into this company
um like i said i had some personal
things come up i went through a divorce
and i decided um because of the finances
of the divorce
that i should
end my tenure with this company i also
didn't want the company to be involved
in the divorce
and i would go work for a
post-production house and there was a
big post-production house
in the city i was living in which was
kansas city it's in the middle of the
u.s
and i built a second demo reel so now
i'm on demo reel number two
and i as i mentioned it was full of spec
work i had a little bit of client work i
sent that off to this post-production
house
and um
they immediately hired me it was pretty
much like no question like hey we want
to offer you a job we want to offer you
this amount of money which was a huge
pay raise for me
and
i knew at the time i was like okay this
is what i need to do i knew i didn't
want to work for somebody for the rest
of my life it's just that's me
personally i like to be my own boss
nothing wrong with you working for
somebody else
so i went to work for them for two years
and during this time
um
i again
kept creating spec work so my work that
i was doing to get paid to do for this
company was was improving i was now
doing regional commercials for like the
lotteries
for internet companies for cell phone
companies
political campaigns things like that
so my work
that i was doing to get paid for was
getting better
but i knew i could still push myself
even further doing spec work so that's
what i did i made even more spec work
worked at this company for two years
at the end of two years i put a third
demo reel together okay now i'm on demo
reel number three
and
excuse me i still have a cough
um
i decided that it was time and i should
mention while i was working for this
company um
i was also doing a little bit of
moonlighting on the side which if you
don't know moonlighting is like having
the day job coming home at night
freelancing a little bit on the side
for a various clients
nights and weekends making extra money
you know the work wasn't amazing
um but it it provided some significant
cash flow
so that's why i was doing it plus the
experience
so two years into this job
third demo reel is done it's full of
mostly spec work
and i sent it off to one person and that
one person was kyle cooper who bringing
you back was the guy who created the
seven title sequence
uh within one hour of crea of sending
that that demo reel off to him
um he called me on the phone i was
very nervous
super nervous
and um
he offered me a freelance position a
remote freelance position
working on an hbo show and
man like that was life life-changing i
said i'm done with my job
gave him my notice
i think it was a one-week notice walked
out
and went remote freelance and the rest
was history right so from that point on
here i was working for kyle cooper for
danny yant
for digital kitchen
um god there's a huge list of agencies
post houses i worked for at that time
and it was really interesting because
i was a remote freelancer like i said
everyone else was in new york chicago la
seattle and here i was in kansas city in
the middle of the u.s
getting paid the same as everyone else
or sometimes more because i asked a
premium
and getting the same work
and building better and better demo
reels
so
at that point that i went freelance
that's when i really considered myself
like this is the pro level i want to be
at
um and all it took was three demo reels
so
my point here is
that
it's all about your demo reel
okay
you don't have to have
the most amazing clients paying you for
this work to be on your demo reel
it's up to you
to create that work yourself it's up to
you to create work that drives you
that is your passion that creatively
fulfills you
and when you create that work
and you put that on a demo reel and you
put that demo reel out to the world
someone out there
is going to see that reel
and be drawn in by what you've created
on that reel and they're going to hire
you
and they're going to pay you
to create that same work for them which
in turn
means that you get to create this work
for them
that work goes on your demo reel and
your demo world gets better
and you keep evolving that way
now
maybe you're happy with creating one
demo reel and going to work for
you know a local company that um like
when i when i first started in video
production uh before i was really into
motion graphics i was doing i was
writing directing producing and editing
commercials for tv but we're talking i
was doing pawn shop commercials used
furniture store commercials
car dealership commercials
and my friends that i worked with were
very happy doing that right that that
they loved it that creatively fulfilled
them it didn't fulfill me which is why i
built demo reel after dim real to keep
moving up the ladder to get to pro level
so my dream my goal was always to
you know working for kyle cooper was
like
check it off the list i mean like that
was
at that point i went high level pro and
um
it was very incredibly fulfilling to me
so it's all about your demo reel so
create spec work
that you love to do it will push you
you will learn how to become a better
motion designer by working through these
projects
you're going to learn
tips and tricks that can speed up your
workflow
that can just make you a better
overall motion designer
so that's what i got for you for my
content today
i just want to tell you how you can i
mean anybody can do this right you know
back in the day
um
since youtube and online courses weren't
a thing
it took me a long time right it took me
seven years
seven years to go from no experience to
hitting pro level with kyle cooper
it took me
just a few years three years actually to
go from no experience to having my own
little company that did very well for
itself
so
to in today's world with having online
mentors and courses like that we have
through motion science
or other online places
you can really speed up your the time
that is required for you to get
to where you're getting paid to do this
i hear a lot of people push back
online saying oh yeah you can become a
professional emotion designer but it
takes years and years of experience and
it's really hard work and you know it
this is not easy to do and i mean some
of that is true but it does not have to
take years and years of experience it
all depends on how much you're willing
to push yourself
um and if you're if you
get some of the tools that are out there
to help you now i guess with your online
courses and mentors
that can really speed up your process
so
um that's what i got for you guys um if
anyone has any questions i'd be happy to
answer for you um here in the next few
minutes before i hop off of here
um
i see a couple people saying mk12 so i
actually lived in the same city as mk12
they were in kansas city as well
i never did work for them i knew a
couple guys through
mutual friends
in fact the guy i started my first
company with in 2003 he actually used to
work with mk12 as their video shooter
great guys great company
super inspirational to me
uh alexander said he began blacksmith i
begin my motion design path with video
copilot great place to begin gosh the
video code had been around when i
started that had been
sped up some time for me for sure
definitely definitely definitely
um
kermit was inspired let's see let me
pull up some
comments here kermit was inspired by
disney's black hole title mtv north by
northwest lots of saul bass amazing
that's awesome
i know when i worked for danny yount
saul bass was a huge influence on him i
never personally got into saw bath so
much just wasn't my jam with the style
but i there's so many things today
created by saul bass you know influenced
by soul bass i should say
uh feron
space jam title sequence i haven't seen
that one
is that the new one or the old one
um let's see here
yeah kermit uh res fest
titles music videos had a lot of
influence on me late 90s early 2000s
same here right we're dating ourselves
but um you know guys what's so cool
about right now is i see a lot of the
late 90s mid 90s to late 90s work coming
back it's full circle right i'm seeing a
lot of it come back
in design and motion design
things to do with grunge that heavy
texture
even color palettes just kind of dirty
work um it looks so great and i'm so
excited about it
excuse me
i could get over this cold
um jay gentry you worked for imaginary
forces no this was uh when kyle cooper
had prologue
so kyle was involved with imaginary
forces with i can't remember who and
they split kyle created prologue uh
picture prologue films that's when i
came to work for them so if you haven't
checked out prologue films check them
out they do amazing work imaginary
forces i mean i absolutely love them i
never
actually set my reel to imaginary forces
so what i found was when i went
um
the high level pro
i had a handful of clients maybe five
six seven of them and they kept me busy
year round and i was happy with the work
i was doing for them and um didn't have
a lot of time to reach out to other
clients so imaginary forces was always
on that list i highly respect what they
do
yeah and david says reading books is a
great way to improve your work yeah
there's some great books out there now
uh i can't think off the top there's one
off the top of my head about style frame
design that's really awesome
uh it's written by austin something
a really great book i'm not a huge
reader of books now
uh zaheed i love your tutorials quick
question how do you charge a client is
it hourly by frame or any other
procedure what is the best for a motion
designer so a great question
zaheed
it really depends on how your client
wants to work with you or
what you put in place different clients
expect different
procedures
so
i did work typically by the day i would
have a day rate
um never really by the hour it was
always by the day
and towards the end
of my freelance career because i did
to be transferring with you guys i quit
freelancing and
my last one was in 2020
because i went full time with motion
science this motion science takes all my
time now
um
at the end of my career it was um
project rate if i could get it
um day rates vary depending on your
experience
from four hundred dollars a day
um up to a thousand dollars a day is
what i was getting sometimes
um a sweet spot for me was 800 a day
that was when i was you know a higher
level pro
motion designer so it just depends you
get more bang for your buck
for you i guess i shouldn't say that you
make more money
typically when you're doing a project
rate if you can work fast so if someone
gives you a like let's say they give you
a thousand dollars and you have um two
days to work on it well if it only takes
you a day you made a thousand dollars in
a day the client doesn't know that
uh if it takes you two days it's 500 a
day
um so it just depends
but hourly
uh not so much when i was designing
style frames
um and i guess i would say designing or
animation didn't really matter
uh it's just there was a day rate or a
project rate
it just really depends on what how you
want to work and how the client's
comfortable is working but i was always
you know straight up with my clients
like if i was working with anybody new
i would just be like hey i charge this
much a day
um does that work for you sometimes they
we don't know and like if if things were
weird in terms of rates i would always
go to my client and say
i know that you have a budget in mind
the client has a budget
they know what they want to spend or
they have to spend it's up to you to get
that out of them if if
if it's kind of weird right if you just
go to them and say hey my rates 800
bucks a day
i think it's going to take me seven days
to do this they know 800 times seven is
this much
and you can go that route too
my first after effects book was after
effects apprentice i had you know 2002.
wow i don't remember that book at all
that's interesting
may have to go back and look at that one
up
um your work is too good if someone
wants to work with you how can join you
so
um
there's a few different ways you can
work with me
number one i have a free workshop at
motionscience.tv
it's a free workshop
it's called the seven secrets to
cinematic motion design i give you some
really powerful tips in there it's
really short
i give you a special offer at the end
for one of my products
um if you
are just looking for something free go
check it out
so there's my free workshop i also have
paid courses if you go to
motionscience.tv
you're going to see my my courses there
they range in price
and i also have a community
and to be part of the community you have
to join stylecraft stylecraft is my
flagship course
and
it's higher priced
but
what stylecraft does is it teaches you
motion and design and
which is very important as a motion
designer
i find that many motion designers
know how to animate but they don't know
how to design
and if you want to be considered
really good at this you need to know
both it's very important you know both
you don't know um have to know
because i also see a lot of them like
they
they focus so much on animation which is
okay but like if you want to be like so
good at animation like maybe you're
going into character animation that was
never my thing
um so you don't have to know that much
animation where it's like this crazy
amount of detail if you know the basics
of animation and you know the basics of
design um you can go far in motion
design so stylecraft is where i teach
that
and sauerkraft comes with a with a
private community
and in that private community i'm in
there
along with a lot of other motion
designers
at all different levels of
professionalism
and we're all there to support each
other and you know if you have questions
or if you want to show your work and get
feedback
all that stuff it's all within the
stylecraft community
let's see here
what is your process for determining how
much time will you invest in a project
versus how complex or intricate the
effects or project is great question
james it just really depends on the
project
when you've done this enough
you'll start to understand how much time
it will take you you never really know
right until you jump into that project
because projects can be filled with
intricacies and things pop up and things
change from when you were hired to do it
to when it actually finishes i mean that
happens all the time a project evolves
so it really just depends
you know you always want to
err on the side of it taking longer
than maybe it will just to be safe
you don't want to over you know
over commit to time and but yet you're
not getting paid for that time
it also you know depending on the
intricacy of the effects
some projects aren't effects heavy
it really just depends on the project um
but again it can also come back to the
client
if a client if if no one really knows
how long a project is going to take
um
i will just say to that client what is
your budget what can you spend on this
and when they tell me that number it's
up to me to decide okay
based on that number i think i can get
it done
or i can't get it done it just really
depends
uh dmc still want to get your starcraft
masterclass i hope to see you in it
hope you're seeing it
i love engaging with everybody inside
the stylecraft community it's awesome
should spec work feature recognized
brands movie titles are better to invent
your own name our own names you know
that's a great question jw
i typically stayed away from
recognized brands
if i'm putting that reel out to the
world
just because i don't want to you know
things today
uh if you have someone's logo in there
and they they catch it like you know
youtube's got a lot of algorithms they
can see things they may say it's
copyrighted material and you don't want
that to happen you don't want to spend a
ton of time on like a coca-cola logo or
a nike logo and find out that oh they've
pulled it down i can't i'm not allowed
to see it it's just a chan something
that you have to you know weigh the
risks
in terms of music i don't use any
copyrighted music anymore because it'll
get pulled down i use epidemic sound
audio jungle a couple other places
for the music track for my reel but um
you know spec work when i first started
i was creating
fake company names fake logos
it's easy today to to find logos out
there that are
you know just created like on envato
elements
free pick
a lot of their sites that have them
just fake companies you could take
something like that and animate it that
would probably be a safe bet you could
try and use a big brand
you know logo and maybe you'll get away
with it maybe not you have to i would
think that like even like nike right
there's so many pieces of content out
there with nike
that maybe you would it wouldn't be an
issue to put that in your spec piece
um
and when i did movie titles i would yeah
i would make up names right like
sometimes i include my own name i would
take my friends names and
flip-flop them
first and last names and do that kind of
stuff
uh
philippe
and i if i pronounce you guys his name
is wrong i'm terrible with names i'm
sorry
i'm a fan of
of work and motion science is there any
black friday promo coming it's quite
expensive here in brazil to get your
master classes uh yeah there's a there's
a deal coming i'm not going to say what
it is
but there is um two deals coming for
um
black friday
we're still working out the details
which is why i can't really talk about
it because things can change
if you're looking for a discount
on a course take the free workshop at
motionscience.tv
it's a huge discount on the after
effects courses after effects one two
and three
at least at the time of this recording
that's what the deal is that can always
change too
good times just want to say thank you
for all the content you put out to the
world
appreciate that
um and like i said guys i am going to
start showing up on tuesdays as often as
possible and doing lives like these
um
dan
daniela i'm so interested in starting my
career as a motion designer what would
you recommend to beginners um
start learning
and start creating
uh that's where the spec work comes from
like make yourself a creative brief all
right um i have a mini course that's
coming out
um it's not out yet but it probably will
be very soon it's how to create your own
spec
creative spec creative brief for spec
work
and um because there is an art form to
it but if you don't want to get wrapped
up in that
just kind of give yourself some creative
constraints i have a youtube video
called um something creative constraints
i can't remember the full title but if
you type in creative constraints motion
science it should pop up
excuse me
um it's important to have creative
constraints
if we have a wide canvas
it can really screw things up and put us
into
locked up mode
so give yourself some creative
constraints maybe take a logo maybe
start with a logo animation right if
that's what interests you now i also
want to say you want to do work that
you're passionate about so if you
daniella if you've seen like for
instance if logo animation really jazzes
you do logo animation if title design
really jazzes you do
one shot from a title sequence don't
focus on an entire title sequence make
one shot because remember
that
demo reels are
filled with
quick shots right at the most they're
three seconds maybe five five there's
nothing over five seconds long typically
um so make one shot make two shots
that's it maybe make two shots from a
title sequence this scene and this scene
they look a little you know they're in
the same world but they're different and
they can be used in two different places
in your demo reel
i see motion designers get caught up in
like oh i want to do title sequences so
i have to make an entire title sequence
don't do that focus on one or two shots
if particle effects is what jazzes you
make a particle scene you know using
particles like trap code particular
uh stardust if 3d is your thing with
particles x particles there's so many
different ways if typography is your
thing make a typography piece if color
is your thing show off your color skills
just start
absorb as much content as you can i
would highly recommend motion science
right i mean that's why i'm here
i think that the content that i produce
is the best content out there
for what i call cinematic motion design
right i teach you high level design and
animation in a very kind of moody style
so check out the motion science courses
definitely do that but just start create
spec work
do you make sound design for your video
i do not um i don't do anything custom
uh for me sound is a huge driving
uh
influencer inspiration for whatever
whatever it is i'm creating
so um i love to go to
audio jungle and find a specific track
that um once i gel with that track i can
riff off of it and design or animate to
it
um i don't do my own sound i years ago i
dabbled in edm music producing it and
using logic pro and things like that so
i know that world
but
it's too time consuming for me to make
custom music so i just there's so much
great music out there
sound design out there it's easy just to
grab packs and put things together if
you need to
um
okay mo what do you like to do if what
do you do if you like to make music
produce music and motion design what
does the path look like or does it even
exist of course it exists
there's like immediately i think of like
creating visuals for artists on stage
right like i
love going to concerts and seeing like
for me nine inch nails has always been
my favorite band since the 90s since
1990 and uh if you go to their show
their visuals are just
so great right because
you're listening to this powerful music
and you're seeing what was created um
it's just it's that's a great merger of
of audio and visual
a lot of dj's today are looking for for
artists to produce their work
it's another revenue to go
um you know i just went to an
interactive interactive art exhibit down
in miami uh where you walk through these
enormous rooms where the graphics it's
motion design graphics motion graphics
that are moving around you it's all put
to music right the sound drives the
visual
so those are just three examples right
there
off the top of my head
touch designer is an amazing program
for
taking um
audio
taking visuals that are driven by audio
it's a different way of working i don't
know a ton about it looking to touch
designer
i mean there's got to be more but
visuals for art for musicians is huge
right now it's only getting bigger
design promotion by austin shaw that is
exactly the book i was talking about
thank you kermit
as an older designer i worry about
ageism thoughts ah okay todd well i mean
like i'm an older emotion designer i
think i'm in the first i consider myself
someone i think chris doe told me i was
in the second group of motion designers
i think i'm in the first group
um which when we started
you know we're in our 20s and we're
chugging along and then we hit 40 and
we're like wait
are they still going to hire us i mean
yes they're still going to hire you
you can move up in positions as well you
can move into creative director
positions
um
excuse me
you can
continue in motion design why not i have
so many students in my stylecraft course
that are in their 50s
60s i have a couple in their 70s and one
in his 80s
uh so you know like and they've had a
variety of careers before this and now
they're learning motion design and the
guy in his 80s he's getting paid he's a
freelancer right doing motion design
so you know
take ageism out of it i i've dealt with
that myself
motion design is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
yes there's a ton of motion designers
out there but the the um
the request for motion design work is
just exponentially exploding
video content is king and it's getting
bigger with video content comes motion
graphics and motion design so they're
married hand in hand
it is getting huge and it's only growing
so the need is there
uh how did you manage your energy to
still learn after coming home from work
i feel exhausted learned so much from
your tutorials awesome heart thank you
it was tough it was tough i'll be honest
with you i had many many late nights and
i just did what i had needed to do
because i had a passion
to want to create more and more and i
wanted to make my life better and i
wanted to make more money while doing
what i love to do i'll tell you guys
when you get to the level of doing
getting paid to do what you love to do
it's not considered a job anymore it's
just it's awesome
i love what i do
now it's mine has kind of evolved into
teaching but i still create
my passion is in creating and i'm
getting paid to create
so
in the beginning you may have to balance
some things but i'm telling you it's
worth it
um
shoddy good evening what's better to
learn java before expressions are just
copy paste except i copy paste
expressions
i don't know a ton about coding
my friends euchremedia.com
those guys are amazing with expressions
for me
my expression is wiggle the wiggle
expression i use it for so many things
it can be used in so many different
capacities
that maybe you don't think about i do
teach some of that a lot of that stuff
with wiggle in my courses in many of my
courses
but i know the wiggle expression if i
need to know something more complex i
will go out and search it and copy paste
uh jay gentry in 2021 how would you
suggest to align yourself with a great
artist cold emails calls seem a little
archaic i mean email is king still i'll
tell you that
people
are tied to their emails so
maybe tied is not the right word but
email's king
reach out
or you know instagram direct message
ask for um maybe if an if an artist you
know mentors
um you know sometimes they're gonna
charge you for it a lot of times they're
gonna charge you for it uh maybe they
won't maybe you'll i don't know it just
depends but you don't know unless you
reach out so you know direct message
through instagram
email
all that good stuff
um
jw really enjoying learning through
starcraft so many visual techniques
thanks man
or thank you
um
hello from russia with love how do you
deal with burnout at work thank you very
much for 3d camera techniques you helped
me a lot at the time awesome uh how do
you deal with burnout well i mean it's
called self-care
man
self-care so it's very very important
that you take care of your yourself as
well
um we're all guilty of not taking care
of ourselves like for me
uh
self-care to me is working out um
at least five days four to five days a
week
when i'm sitting here i can get really
tight and tensed up it's important for
me to work out to just feel better my
body i also get massages all the time
right i also see the chiropractor all
the time this is stuff i did not used to
do when i was younger my body paid the
price
when i first started out
uh i did a lot of i had a lot of bad
habits
um but it's all about self-care make
sure you get plenty of rest it's all
about right you know for me i've found
that i have to like eight to nine hours
is ideal for me for sleeping i have
friends that need five hours and they do
just great it just depends on who you
are but just have self-care if you don't
have self-care you will burn out and
it won't be good
uh george you love your channel really
powerful stuff do you review people's
reels to see if it's working on selling
the presenter i do not i do not um
something i'm bringing into stylecraft
very soon is called feedback fridays
where i will be reviewing uh people's
work from stylecraft that
eventually gets ends up on reels i see
most
students
you know building projects in stylecraft
and it goes on the reels and
550 who's on the chat right now made an
amazing demo reel
all based on stylecraft work
um something else um
well i'm not going to mention that i may
in the future i may do some some group
coaching for people but at this time i
don't
i'm not looking to be pro level
emotional i just want to have some skill
to present my work to the client so what
is the best of your tutorial work for me
it really depends on what you want to do
my tutorials focus on technical
processes they focus on design
effects it just depends you know at pro
level it to me pro can is getting paid
for what you do that could be
pro you could be a pro level here you
could be here here here i mean there's
all different levels of pro level to me
that's just getting paid for what you do
uh any chance of starcraft will go on a
discounted price
um
at this time new
i starcraft is already pretty cheap in
my opinion it used to go for a lot more
money than it is now
um i redid a lot of things for it and
it's still a heck of a deal
[Music]
uh cameron thanks for all your lessons
looking forward to black friday
promotions i'm waiting for an
opportunity to jump into motion science
courses greetings from brazil living in
portugal awesome uh yeah and i should
say um
to the comment uh tio
starcraft i mean there's there's a good
chance starcraft's gonna have a discount
on black friday like i said things are
not finalized though
um
so
i don't want to promise anything
um
but i'm seriously looking at that
giorgio i saw a tutorial you did with a
gradual fade out can't find anymore any
help finding it um yeah i think that's
in my workshop
if it has to do with fades to black it's
a really cool technique
fading to black that you most people
don't think of and it's very cinematic
look at the free workshop
freeworkshop.motionscience.tv
ah thanks for the super chat i
appreciate that
that's awesome thank you
you're welcome todd awesome awesome
uh yeah this video is gonna stay up for
a while
l it will be up
like i said i'm gonna start doing these
on tuesdays as much as possible
loop out's a great expression yes and so
is the time expression so in after
effects academy i talk about those two
expressions as well
uh it's just for me wiggle has always
been like
so powerful for me
uh
thanks i'm og awesome thank you
how do you deal with perfectionism
deadlines
um
hmm
well okay so i never miss a dead that's
a great question never miss a deadline
ever
um that is a big no-no you don't ever
want to if you miss a deadline i've
hired freelancers for me that missed
deadlines they're never hired again
every company i know that hires a
freelancer who misses a deadline they're
never hired again you don't miss a
deadline if anything you deliver before
that deadline
uh perfectionism is at some point you
have to say i need to let this piece go
um
for me i typically do three rounds of
revisions okay
and that means that i get the piece
well it really depends on the p how long
the piece is but a lot of times
i get it to maybe sixty percent there
seventy percent i send it off to the
client
and i let them know that like hey this
is
over halfway
in terms of how to look i just want to
get feedback make sure everything is
great no major changes if any revisions
happen great if none i keep moving
forward then i get it to about
85 there
maybe 90 there
again
how does it look great okay
final revision is where i take it to
that next level with my polish the
finishing effects
which i teach a lot of that in
stylecraft that's what takes it to that
next level and typically a client
because everything's been signed off on
i do those finishing things client sees
it wow factor done
so you have to allow the time in there
for those three rounds of revisions
sometimes it's less than three sometimes
it's two sometimes it's one there's
always some type of revision i don't
ever go beyond three if it goes beyond
three rounds of revisions there's extra
money involved
time is money
i have other clients typically waiting
in the wings to work with me and if a
deadline is a deadline if the client is
going to try and move that deadline or
push revisions at that point you know
there's extra costs involved
okay that was the last question so i'm
going to wrap this one up uh i want to
say thank you to everyone who showed up
today looks like there was a great
turnout
lots of great comments um
questions uh you guys are awesome so
i'm gonna push you if you haven't
checked out a motion science course
please do uh i promise you won't be
disappointed i put a lot of time and
effort into these courses i also have
two other guys who help me with some of
these courses ryan and shannon
we have a very high level of quality
and
we stand by that
and very proud of the courses at motion
science
so
um
check out the free workshop you will get
a discount on some of the courses right
now that's an incredible discount that
uh it's not gonna last forever so
um
again thank you everyone for being here
for listening to me talk hopefully you
learned something today hopefully you
got something out of this i hope that
you did
and uh hope to see you guys next tuesday
at 1 pm eastern
for
motion science live
see you guys very very soon